Okay.
Let's go ahead and get started. Welcome to the session on
RNA biology and cancer.
Pardon me. My name is Paul Bouts. I'm from the University of Rochester,
and the Wilmot Cancer Institute. We just recently
got our NCI Cancer Center designation this last year.
Thank you.
Our other speakers today will be Dr.
Megan Inscho, who's at Dana-Farber.
She's also
in the Department of Medicine at Harvard Med School and is
also a working medical oncologist specializing in melanoma.
And Omar Abdelwahab,
who's the chair of the Molecular Pharmacology program at Sloan Kettering,
also an attending physician in the leukemia
service.
And,
really the model of physician scientists, both of
these
guys here. I'm really lucky to be speaking with them
today. Advance my
slides here.
So today's session is dedicated to the memory of David Baltimore,
and his impact on many
fields is really immeasurable,
especially here at this meeting, from his
discoveries of NF-kappa B, the RAG
enzymes involved in immunoglobulin
recombination,
the first BCR-ABL mouse model, which was
instrumental in the development of Gleevec.
And none of those things are what he won the Nobel Prize for, which
was the discovery of reverse transcriptase.
And,
I can guarantee you that today, in every talk you'll see in this
session, reverse transcriptase was used in almost
every slide. The impact of that
discovery is just immeasurable. And so David
was truly a giant among giants.
So it's very fitting that this session honors
him today.
So I'm going to give a brief introduction to try to
put the work that you'll be hearing about today
into a bigger picture context.
And so, there's a very large
RNA world in mammalian cells.
And
in many cases, we tend to focus on
these mRNA protein coding
genes,
and those are certainly
a very important
type of RNA that
we'll all be talking about today.
But there are also other groups of RNAs, for example, long
non-coding RNAs, which touch on
my talk,
as well as
RNAs that are derived from selfish elements like
transposable elements, endogenous retroviruses.
And so Megan will be speaking about those today.
So,
an mRNA has, of course, a very
complex life cycle. And I just want to point out that
these early stages in RNA processing, the spliceosome, is really
well positioned to impact all of these
downstream events in an mRNA's
life. And that's because of the
nature of the transcript is determined by its
splicing and its polyadenylation,
and that can include sequences that change its subcellular
localization, its protein coding sequence, and
translation efficiency, but also how it's
ultimately degraded, how it's decayed,
which
brings this life cycle into full circle.
And
so,
the first talk I will be giving today
will touch on
both the role of long non-coding RNAs in generating
these nuclear bodies that
were discovered decades ago,
and have been known to be associated with splicing,
but the actual mechanistic underpinnings of how
these function has remained unclear.
So my talk will touch on this area.
Megan
has done a lot of work in the area of
understanding how nuclear RNA surveillance
pathways
can clean up and eliminate
potentially oncogenic
RNA molecules. And so in previous work, she showed
how this was related to the function of
a transcriptional kinase, CK13.
And she's then gone on to do further work to
understand how these pathways can
additionally clean up
selfish elements. So this is a very
complicated process, well characterized by
Torben Jensen's group
as well as Lynne Maquat and Xavier Rambeau at
University of Rochester,
where they've really begun to characterize how these
unique complexes are responsible
for suppressing tumors by
preventing the expression of many classes of
oncogenic RNAsIn our
third talk, Omar, who's done an
immense amount of work in the field of splicing mutations in
cancer.
We know now a great deal about mechanistically how
these mutations are affecting splicing.
Work from Rob Bradley and Omar have shown how
these mutations can switch the specificity of
a RNA-binding protein.
And Freda-Lynn's group
generated these beautiful structures which really show us how
mechanistically this works by where
this P95 mutation prevents
the rotation of the base molecule in
such a way that it can no longer fit into this binding pocket.
And so in a sense, this protein is locked into
only being able to bind a subset of its substrates.
The question now is then how does this go on
to generate
cancer cell biology, but also how can we
therapeutically target that? And so Omar's talk today will
focus on an exciting area of this that
stems from this,
which is that many of these
splicing events that are happening in tumors with mutations
can generate neoantigens, which have not been
tolerated to the immune system and therefore may serve
as
targeted antigens for therapy.
So, let me start with my
slides.
Okay. So,
the work I'm going to tell you about today
focuses on sort of a relatively new
biology
around this phenomenon of the liquid-liquid
phase separation. And you can think of this
as
sort of like a lava lamp, where you have two
liquid phases which are
touching each other, which are in
equilibrium with each other, but which have
a very different composition within
them. And so if you zoom into this bubble in your lava lamp,
it's going to look something like this over here,
where you have the driving force behind these
phenomenon
are, in fact,
multivalent interactions, and these can occur both between
proteins and RNA. And in fact,
RNA is an ideal multivalent
nucleator because it can interact with multiple
RNA-binding proteins simultaneously.
And so
two such condensates that have been known, as I mentioned before,
for decades
are the paraspeckle, shown in green here, and the
nuclear splicing speckle, shown in red.
These are usually located adjacent to each other.
And the work that I'll show you today started in the
lab of my colleague, Stefano Mello.
When he was a postdoc with Laura Attardi, he did this work
on the RNA scaffold of
paraspeckles. And so this RNA
is called NEAT1. It's a long non-coding RNA.
It forms the basis or the body of the
paraspeckle, and then many other proteins are associated with
that. And what Stefano found is that if you knock these out in mice,
the NEAT1 is actually functioning as a tumor suppressor.
So if you remove it and paraspeckles,
you get much more aggressive tumor growth.
And so his grad student, and then he
became co-mentored with me, Dikari Astegani, really
spearheaded all of the work that I'm going to show you today.
And he began trying to understand what paraspeckles were
doing here. By the way, the timer is
stuck. Thanks.
Okay. So the first thing Dikari did was when he looked at
RNA sequencing
from these NEAT1 knockout cells, he noticed that a certain
type of splicing event called a detained intron, which I'll
explain in a minute,
essentially was missing in these NEAT1 knockout
cells. And this also correlated with
a strong upregulation in a number of splicing factor
gene expression.
When he looked at pancreatic
cancer
data from The
Cancer Genome Atlas, he found a similar pattern where
certain basal subtypes were also
lacking detained introns. And this correlated with
the progression-free survival, where the
low DI group had much worse prognosis.
So what are detained introns? Detained introns are
unspliced introns in otherwise fully
spliced and polyadenylated messages.
And they form pre-splicesomes,
but these splicesomes stall out prior to catalysis.
And this traps these RNAs in the
nucleus where ultimately they undergo
decay.And incidentally, I will point
out that David Baltimore was one of the first to
describe this
phenomenon where the rate of splicing can be
limiting for gene expression.
And so these detained introns are different from
what we call retained introns, which are introns that actually get
exported and undergo translation.
So, coming back to this
pancreatic model. So in pancreatic
cancer, the molecular work has really
coalesced into two subtypes,
two general subtypes. The classical subtype, which
is more epithelial, less invasive, the basal
subtype, which is more mesenchymal, more aggressive.
And these can be characterized by gene expression scores
of a small subset of genes that correlate with these subtypes.
So
when
Stefano's lab started looking into the
differences between these cell types using
a series of cell lines that are
pancreatic cancer derived,
they found using in situ hybridization that NEAT1
expression and therefore paraspeckles, are
much more prevalent in the classical subtypes compared to
basal.
And in fact, if they knocked out NEAT1,
they could see a change in the marker expression from
classical to more basal-like.
And so, in conjunction with Isaac Harris's
group at University of Rochester, Isaac has a very
nice screening library for
small molecules that specifically target metabolic pathways.
And so using a cell line developed by
Tetsura Hirose,
which are Hap1 myeloid leukemia cells, these are
haploid cells which are often used for knockout studies.
NEAT1-deficient cells versus NEAT1-competent
cells were then screened in this library.
And a number of compounds came out
in which cells that lacked NEAT1 were sensitized to
these drugs.
And particularly those relating to redox
homeostasis and autophagy or ER stress
were particularly enriched.
And so if we look at those individual drugs, we could see that
indeed the NEAT1 knockout cells in all of these
top hits were in fact more sensitive.
And two of those,
the very top of those hits corresponded to these
two drugs here, RSL3 and
ML162. These are GPX4
inhibitors.
GPX4 uses glutathione
to reduce the oxidative damage
to lipids, which, if left unchecked, can lead
to an iron-dependent type of programmed cell death
called ferroptosis.
And so these two drugs that were
sensitized in cells lacking NEAT1 are
both GPX4 inhibitors, suggesting that
ferroptosis sensitivity could be the
hallmark of these cells. So, Decari reasoned then
that if we co-treat with an inhibitor of ferroptosis
called ferrostatin 1,
that this
could suppress the phenotype. And so he did this
in a little bit different cell line, which now
not only is NEAT1 deficient, but it's only deficient
for the longer isoform of NEAT1, which is the
one that scaffolds paraspeckles,
and the shorter polyadenylated isoform is left
intact.
And indeed, so when Decari
treated these cells lacking paraspeckle isoform, shown
in red here, they are sensitive and
ferrostatin was able to at least partially
reverse the sensitivity. So this told us that
the paraspeckle form of NEAT1
is
critical for
protecting cells from ferroptosis.
So this was all done, as I mentioned, in a myeloid leukemia
cell for technical reasons. So the next question is
whether, going back now to the PDAC models,
do these observations hold?
And so looking again at
the paraspeckle
prevalence within classical versus basal, there's a
clear reduction in paraspeckle levels
in the basal-like cells.
And in fact,
if you just treat these cells with RSL3
straight up, the basal-like cells are indeed more sensitive
to these drugs.
So,
Decari next wanted to see if he can modulate the
levels of paraspeckles through controlling the
expression of NEAT1. And so he did this using a
CRISPR system, CRISPRi, which can
transcriptionally repressNEAT1, and this works
very, very well. They become undetectable in these
guide RNA-treated cells.
And in fact, just by
depleting NEAT1,
Dikari could see that the gene expression
score, that PAMG score, shifts to a more
basal-like
expression pattern.
And then when he treated these cells,
several different cell lines,
both with NEAT1 knockdown and
then applied the GPX4 inhibitor,
we can see that indeed the loss of NEAT1
sensitizes these
cells to
the drug.
So next he asked, "Can we go the opposite direction?" So if we
take
MiaPaCa cells, which are more basal-like cells, and
now use CRISPRa to activate the
expression transcriptionally of NEAT1, what
happens? And so the first thing is that we can
indeed
increase these NEAT1 paraspeckle
using CRISPRa.
And so we get a
higher number of paraspeckles in these cells.
And then what happens if we treat with the drugs?
So,
in these cells now, these are now basal-type cells,
which we've boosted the paraspeckle levels
in them. And indeed, there's a slight but significant
increase in their resistance to the
ferroptosis-inducing drugs.
So this told us then that NEAT1 induction is sufficient
to increase the resistance to these inhibitors in PDAC
cells.
So Dikari went on to do further work, which I don't
have time to go into great detail about, but he was
able to find an RNA-binding protein called
quaking,
which is involved in the biogenesis of
NEAT1.
So
quaking actually suppresses that
longer NEAT1 isoform and therefore
reduces paraspeckle levels.
So if Dikari knocked out quaking,
he could see an increase in the relative expression level of
NEAT1, but more specifically, he could see that
the long isoform, the paraspeckle
isoform, increased significantly,
and there were more NEAT1 foci per nucleus
in those cells.
So
next, Dikari asked, "How do these cells respond to the
GPX4 inhibitors?" And so in
these Sut2 cells which have NEAT1 knocked
down,
as we saw before, there's an increase in the sensitivity.
But if you instead knock out quaking, so you increase the
level of long NEAT1 paraspeckle,
this actually pushes the opposite direction and even
increases the resistance slightly in these
cells.
And so these experiments
place quaking upstream of
NEAT1 in the biogenesis of paraspeckles.
And so this is really a dynamic process.
So, not only is this cell type dependent,
but these factors are responsive to stress.
For example, NEAT1 can be upregulated
by p53.
So paraspeckles, we know then from this
work that they suppress
oxidative stress pathways. So now the question becomes:
What are they actually doing to gene expression and
splicing?
And so I want to come back
to the beginning of this talk where
I was talking about retained introns.
And
so we started to think about another collaboration that we did
with Suzanne Walker's group at Harvard,
where we found that if you treat with inhibitors
of this enzyme called OGT, this is a
glycosyltransferase. It puts this O-linked glucanac
molecule onto serine and threonine residues,
and this is really
mutually exclusive with many kinases that would
phosphorylate the same residues.
So if you treat with an inhibitor of this drug, prevent
glucanac, this upregulates phosphoproteins,
specifically in many splicing factors.
And if we look now at splicing
levels, we see this really striking specificity where
we essentially lose retained introns when we
inhibit OGT,
and other splicing events are relatively unaffected.
We could drive this in the opposite direction using an
OGA inhibitor. So preventing the removal of
glucanac increases glucanac modifications.
And so we asked next whether in
these pancreatic cancer cell
linesWhat happens if we treat with these
modulators of OGA or OGT? And in fact,
particularly when we increase the
GluCNAC
levels in these cells, we see a strong
increase in the level of paraspeckles.
And many of these paraspeckle-associated proteins
are known to be modified by OGT.
And so we think that
this is kind of our working model, is
that these nuclear bodies sort of
coexist and that
paraspeckles are really defined and probably
placed in distinct nuclear
chromatin neighborhoods or
individual loci through modifications of
histones and associated splicing
factors in those bodies may be predominantly
GluCNAC modified, resulting in splicing inhibition,
retention of those intron-containing isoforms
within these bodies.
Whereas nuclear speckles are driven by
phosphorylation, have high splicing activity and
high export activity.
So, I just want to thank you all for being here
and the organizers for the opportunity to
talk with you today.
This is my lab here. Dakari, in the Star Wars shirt
here is the main guy on this work. But
most of this work was done in Stefano
Mello's group at U of R,
along with Isaac Harris and Zemira, Krista, Fabio,
Sara, and Christina all contributed.
And this is our funding, and I'll take questions
now.
So if you
have a question, you could step up to one of the microphones
here, and please just
tell us who you are and where you're coming from.
Anyone?
Here
we go.
Mustafa Alshani from St. Andrews University, Scotland.
The detained introns element, is it a
regulatory element to just keep
the actual transcripts in the nucleus until it's needed by a cue,
or is it a non-mediated decay type of transcript?
Is it regulated as needed?
Yes. Fantastic question. So the question is,
what is the mechanism behind how detained introns
affect gene expression? And
the answer to that is actually both of the
descriptions you gave are true in different cases.
So in some cases,
these detained introns can
form a sort of a pool of RNAs that are
mostly spliced but may be lacking one intron.
They're ready to go,
and these can actually be triggered to undergo full
splicing by some cellular signal.
And so there's work in neurons, for
example, that indicate that
neuronal genes can undergo this type of regulation.
And it makes a lot of sense.
Many neuronal genes are very, very long, would take
hours or more to transcribe through.
So you can imagine that having this ready pool upon
a signal to be spliced is important
there. In other cases, though, these actually
represent sort of dead-end transcripts.
So
in many cases,
the detained intron isoform will only form
if the splice variant that would result in
nonsense-mediated decay is chosen.
So in other words,
even if those
detained introns are spliced, it creates a
transcript that will then undergo decay.
So in some cases, it really represents a
negative gene expression regulatory pathway.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Did you also see a long non-coding
having detained introns?
Yeah, so that's a good question. So the way that we've defined
these makes it difficult to address that question because
we use sort of as our--
So if you were to do a nuclear versus
cytoplasmic localization, you could answer that question.
In many datasets, we don't have that level of resolution.
Yeah.
So we have to infer by the fact that those
molecules don't undergo NMD, that they are
in fact detained introns. So it's a more technical question.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Hi. This is Guiping Wang from Stanford University.
Hi.
I'm curious, if you delete the
paraspeckle protein components, do you have the same effect, or is it
specific to non-coding RNA NEAT1 here?
Yes.
Thank you.
Great question. So the question is, if you deplete the
specific proteins that are paraspeckle associated,
do you also deplete paraspeckles the same way that
NEAT1 depletion does? And we haven't done those
experiments, but others have and shown that in fact,
there are essential
proteinsfor paraspeckle
formation that you can do exactly what you said, which
is deplete protein factors that will dissolve
those bodies.
And I assume they have the same effect
as human?
Yes. So we haven't looked at that. We've specifically only looked at
Neat1 depletion in our work.
So I can't answer that question.
Thank you.
Thanks.
Okay.
One more.
Hey. I'm Ben Gralik from Mercer University in Georgia.
I have a follow-up question about the proteins in the
paraspeckle.
So a lot of them, like FUS and UWS-
Mm-hmm
... are RNA-binding proteins-
Yep
... but also can be
transcriptionally active-
Mm-hmm
... or they can activate transcription.
So I guess I was wondering
if you deplete Neat1 and you lose the
sequestering of these proteins and they're
loose in the nucleus, do you think that might have
implications for dysregulating gene expression at the
transcriptional level?
Yes, great question. The question is,
are we actually by dissolving paraspeckles,
scattering active proteins that would normally not
be present in these other locations?
And so I think the answer is probably yes in some
cases, though we think that
with regard to paraspeckles and speckles,
there's probably a lot of transit
between the two, and that as one grows, the
other shrinks.
So I would guess that a lot of those factors might
simply move over into another
condensate. But it's a great question.
Awesome. Thank you.
Okay, so we're out of time for this.
So our next speaker will be Megan Ensko.
Hi.
Thanks so much for having me to talk today, and I'm really excited to tell
you about our work regarding RNA as a cancer driver.
And Paul already gave my introduction, so I had to remember to skip that.
Okay, so as this audience well knows, from discoveries in
RNAi to splicing to more recent discoveries in nuclear export
control and RNA modifications, these companies and
many others are bringing these basic science discoveries to
patients. And so this is a really important and exciting area to do basic
science that has relevance to therapeutic development.
And so since RNA is so important, RNA fidelity is
key. And again, this audience is well aware of cytoplasmic processes
such as nonsense-mediated decay and double-stranded RNA surveillance.
But what Paul already alluded to is that I'm going to focus on nuclear
RNA surveillance, and this is a more recently described
and less well understood process that degrades aberrant or unstable
RNAs in the nucleus. And I'm going to talk about this because I found this
process to be tumor suppressive.
And in terms of outline, I'm going to cover how I came to be
interested in nuclear RNA surveillance very briefly through the CDK13
story. And then I'm going to spend most of the time telling you about the first
independent story from my lab involving
ZC3H18 and its specific regulation of oncogenic
endogenous retroviral RNA.
So I was really excited when this work came out in 2023.
So in this work, we found that CDK13 in melanoma,
specifically by binding cyclin T1, phosphorylates a residue on this
ZC3H14 protein, which then recruits this degradation
complex, which is in the nucleus, to degrade a very specific kind of aberrant
RNA from protein coding genes called these prematurely terminated RNAs or
prematurely terminated transcripts.
When CDK13 is mutated, this phosphorylation fails to occur,
the PAX complex is not recruited, and these prematurely terminated transcripts are
stabilized and actually accumulate in the cells.
Importantly, CDK13 mutations are related to
elevated levels of these ptrRNAs in patient samples,
are associated with worse overall survival in patients, and can
cause worse melanoma in a zebrafish animal model as well as
making human melanoma cells grow more quickly.
Also importantly, there are recurrent mutations in additional members of this
complex, and the ptrRNAs themselves are sufficient to
expedite oncogenesis. So I'm just going to show you two pieces of
data from this story since it's published, but just to emphasize the idea that
RNA can be a driving factor in cancer.
I think as the third major
biomolecule, we oftentimes forget that it too may have a major function,
and this is very much understudied.
So the first piece of data I'll show you is that in CDK13 mutant
patients, that we get elevation of these ptrRNAs,
just to show you this is relevant for patients.
And the second thing-- Actually, before I show that, I'll just say that
I trained in Lynn Zond's lab, and so when I do functional genetics, we put
everything through a zebrafish system, and so I will introduce you to the
zebrafish. There may not be a lot of that at ACR.
In the zebrafish system, this is a wild-type fish with its stripes.
This is the melanoma model zebrafish.
This entire fish is mutant for p53 and for
MITFA, the master transcriptional regulator of the melanocyte lineage.
The entire fish also
has oncogenic human BRAF under an MITFA promoter.
So what you do is you take embryos from this fish and you inject
DNA that rescues MITFA in a cell autonomous manner, linked manner.
You can express or knock out anything you want.
And here we're expressing ptrRNAs.And so these were
the, I'm missing a ton, not showing a ton of the mechanistic data in this
paper. But I just want to show you this one, where if you take these ptrRNAs
here, this one is from this locus, involves three different exons, and then
it terminates in this intron. And so this is what's actually expressed.
If you take exactly what's expressed, what accumulates in the CDK13
mutant cells and put it into fish, it
expedites oncogenesis very dramatically.
And expression of additional ptrRNAs have done the same.
My lab is now working on this mechanism, and we're working on ways to target this
through synthetic lethal immune microenvironment and other mechanisms.
Okay, so now I'm going to tell you the first story from my lab,
and this is the follow-up. I told you that there were recurrent truncating
mutations in other members of this complex, and I picked the most
frequent one to go after first.
And so this is ZC3H18. And these recurrent truncating
mutations occur just upstream of the decay domain or the domain
that's known to recruit the RNA surveillance binding machinery.
Through multiple genetic tools, we found that these mutations are selected for,
and importantly, 35% of melanoma patients have mono or biallelic
loss. And in GISTIC, deletion of this occurs in
almost 30% of all cancers, mostly epithelial cancers.
So this is going to affect a large number of patients.
So we put this Z18 truncation into the zebrafish
melanoma model, and it expedited oncogenesis.
So next, I want to tell you a bit about how these complexes are organized before I
tell you more of the data.
And this involves how these RNAs are recognized in RNA surveillance.
So analogous to how trash is sorted into recycling
streams, different kinds of barren or unstable RNAs in the nucleus
are sorted for degradation by these complexes and probably many others.
I already told you about PAXed and ptrRNAs with the CDK13 story.
But here, I'm also going to mention Next, because Next is
responsible for degradation of promoter upstream transcripts, enhancer RNAs, and
retrotransposon messages, which is really a huge range of substrates to
recognize. And I'll also just mention here that although
we know this works because of mostly genetics, how exactly
from a biochemical perspective these complexes are recognizing their substrates
is really a nascent field.
So Z18 itself, and I'm going to call it Z18 for the rest of the talk instead of
the long name, is part of two of these complexes, Next and
PAXed. And given the CDK13 work, first, we looked
at ptrRNAs with Paul's help. He helped us do this, and
they were unchanged in this system.
Next, because we had polyadenylated RNA sequencing, we looked at retrotransposons,
some of which are polyadenylated, and these were wildly upregulated.
Other Next targets were also unaffected.
So it really had a specific phenotype in the fish of ERV and LTR
transcripts upregulated. This is what this looks like.
So this was in collaboration with Kathy Burns' lab and using a tool called
Squire, which is specifically used to quantify retroelements.
And this involves just uniquely mapping reads.
So in the zebrafish melanoma, if you look at the Z18 trunk versus control
on the vertical axis and the log2 fold change on the horizontal, you can see this
wild upregulation of these specific ERVs called BIC2 elements.
So in zebrafish, these BIC2 elements are transiently expressed during neural
crest development, which is a precursor to melanocyte development.
They are required for neural crest development and also are reactivated upon
melanoma initiation in the fish. So it's pretty interesting.
So we next wanted to know whether this was just a fish thing or
whether it was relevant to humans.
And so next, I'm going to tell you about what we know about transposable elements
in humans very briefly. I'm talking about ERVs, which are a subset of
LTRs, which make up about 8% of the proportion of the human genome.
In terms of structure, they have these two long terminal repeats at the end and
then have a number of ORFs in the middle.
They're thought to be derived from ancient viral infections.
And in humans, importantly, ERVs have accumulated mutations rendering them
non-mobile.
So in CCLE cell lines, so human cell lines from all different cancers,
we asked the question of whether this was relevant, whether the ERV upregulation
would occur in Z18 mutant tumors, and it definitely did.
In fact, we saw multiple classes of retroelements up with ERVs the most
affected, with some of the outliers being very strongly affected.
And this is with 11 mutant patients or cell lines, excuse me, and
control wild type cell lines that are cancer type, oncogene, and sex matched.
So next, we wanted to know if this happened in patients.
So on the left is the CCLE, just a different way to plot the CCLE
data I just showed you. But on the right, we have TCGA melanoma and
TCGA uterine cancer, and it's also true for colon, although I'm not showing that.
And basically, on the blue, you can see in the Z18 mutant tumors that ERVs
are very significantly upregulated.
So next, we wanted to know if this was functional.
So we went to human melanoma cell lines, and we wanted to specifically
clone the heterozygous truncating mutation that occurs.
Also, because in the CDK13 work, we figured out that CDK13 mutations worked
in a dominant negative mechanism, we were suspicious it might be true here
too. So we designed this experiment in a way to test a dominant negative
hypothesis. So we compared the heterozygous truncating mutations to
heterozygous loss of function mutations to a full loss of function with bulk CRISPR
and then pursued RNA sequencing. I'm not going to show you all that data.
It's a lot of data. But the take home is that retrotransposon messages
were significantly upregulated and again, especially ERV
messages. A second thing was that GSEA showed that the most
upregulated pathways were related to viral mimicry, suggesting that the dominant
effect of Z18 mutations was this effect on
retroelements.I will show you
this IGV plot, and this is one RNA that was affected.
And here you can see in the bulk CRISPR, this is Z18 CRISPR, that this
transcript goes up. And then single cell clone lines in the Z18 trunc over
plus, this transcript is also way up, way over what you see in a
heterozygous loss of function. And the trunc over plus approaches the
levels you see in the bulk Z18 CRISPR.
So this shows that
Z18 trunc works in a dominant negative fashion on these RNAs.
Because we showed that this worked in a dominant negative way, we were then able to
exogenously express the trunc, and we showed that for
melanoma cells and in colon cancer cell lines that we had the exact
same ERV upregulation. We also saw that it was specific for
transposable elements and not for other NEST substrate RNAs
such as the enhancer RNAs or upstream antisense.
So we had more of these RNAs. Because the complexes we're dealing with, we presumed
it was because the messages were more stable, but we wanted to test that, so we did
a pulse chase. This is in the exogenous expressing cell lines.
4SU pulse with a two-hour chase, and indeed, these messages were more
stable. And it was also true for the CRISPR
HDR single cell clone cell lines, where these messages were more stable.
So we wanted to know how this works, so we did IP mass spec, and we did this on the
wild type Z18 and then on the truncated Z18.
And as expected with the RNA phenotype, the most
abundant proteins that we pulled down as a percent of Z18 bait were members of the
next complex, which made total sense.
We also got PC1, which I'll tell you why I'm
sharing that in a moment.
The truncated version lost binding to the very important
parts of the next complex, the key helicase and adapter protein.
But surprisingly, it actually maintained or had better binding to these other two
RNA-binding proteins. SRRT is a CAP binding protein, and this
is the poly-A tail binding protein.
And so what this showed us was that Z18 wild type indeed bound to
the next nuclear RNA surveillance complex, and the
truncated version lost the degradation machinery but maintained binding to two
RNA-stabilizing proteins.
So now we had dominant negative activity, and I wanted to put together a couple of
potential models to explain this.
In the first model, I imagined that the Z18 trunc was
sequestering the exosome and the wild type away from the RNA.
In the second one, maybe it's binding the RNA and sequestering it from the exosome
and the wild type.
Z18 trunc did not IP with the full length, making Model 1
unlikely. But in Model 2, what we actually figured out through two
different assays that I'm not going to show you is that Z18 trunc actually
mislocalizes to the cytoplasm.
And so the hypothesis then is that Z18 trunc binds and sequesters the ERV
RNA away from the decay complex in the cytoplasm.
To test this, we did base scope, which is a really sensitive RNA FISH technique
in the control and Z18 lines. And what you can see here, the blue is the
DAPI marking the nucleus, and then you can see here that the red really
shows up in the cytoplasm, so the ERV RNA is accumulating in the
cytoplasm, quantified here.
So that supported Model 1, and so we
were wondering if the Z18 actually was directly binding the ERV RNA.
And so to think about how this could be working, we looked at the
conservation of Z18, and the two major domains that are really
conserved are the RNA surveillance binding domain, which I already told you about,
and then this CCCH zinc finger domain.
So this is actually what the Z18 protein is named for, ZC3H,
and so we looked at this. Now, there's no crystal structure for Z18 yet,
so we modeled this on an existing
CCCH domain protein called
RBM22 to kind of imagine how this could be interacting with RNA.
So if you do this, the CCCH would
bind with zinc, which makes total sense.
But what's really cool is that there are a couple of, actually three, highly
conserved aromatic amino acids which stick out from the zinc finger domain and are
predicted to intercalate with RNA and directly bind RNA
through pi-pi stacking. And so we wanted to test whether Z18 was
directly binding ERV RNA by mutating these residues.
To answer this question, we did a PAR-CLIP experiment.
I'm not going to go into the details, but essentially what you do is pull down the
protein and ask what RNAs come with it.
And so what we did was did this for Z18 full length, the truncated
version with an aromatic amino acid mutant, and then had a negative control.
And what we found was the full length and the trunc bound a ton of different
retroelement messages, whereas that binding was mostly abrogated
in the aromatic zinc finger mutant.
So lastly,
the key thing, and this ended up being the key thing at the end of the CDK13 paper
too, is we showed all this regulation by Z18 on these endogenous retroviral
RNAs. But are those RNAs themselves responsible for the Z18
phenotype? And so to answer this, we turned back to the zebrafish.
And first, we took the BIC2 elements that were upregulated or stabilized in the
fish and expressed them back into the animal model, and both of
them expedited oncogenesis. As far as I'm aware, this is the first
evidence that implicates ERV RNA as being functional in cancer.
And also, it's pretty interesting because ERVs or LTRs are the most highly
expressed repeat element in multiple types of cancer.
And so maybe this is functional and not just a bystander.
So next, we tried a crazy experiment. I had to convince my postdoc to do this.
We took the two most highly Z18-regulated ERVs from human
cells and then put them in the fish.
And what was remarkable is that they actually expedited oncogenesis too.
And so as this is a human ERV that's regulated by Z18 and the
primary sequence is not conserved, it's very different between different
species. However, it suggests a shared feature because Z18 is
regulating them in both of these very different animals, and we're getting
oncogenesis. So I think there's a shared underlying mechanism here
of recognition that we're working on.So next, we wanted
to
test the necessity, because I showed you overexpression that can always
come with caveats. And so to test the necessity in a zebrafish system, we had
to create a CRISPR-I system, which we did.
We adapted the system I explained earlier to inhibit
for CRISPR-I. And here, as proof of concept, we inhibited a gene
involved in pigmentation, and you can see the embryos on the right are less
pigmented, so it worked.
So next, we used this to answer the question of whether the ERV RNA itself
was required for the Z18 phenotype.
It does nothing in the GFP tumors, but in the Z18 tumors,
in the dark blue there, it reverses the oncogenesis
entirely. So it says that the Z18 phenotype was really due to
the ERV RNA.
We next did this in human cells, and remarkably, this experiment was actually hard
to do because it killed all the cells.
So CRISPR-I in the cells was a very
effective killer.
So to put all this together, Z18 mutations
cause accumulation of endogenous retroviral RNA, and there's
recurrent truncating mutations in this, and it's deleted in up to a third of
all cancers, mostly epithelial cancers.
Whether you're a patient that has this deleted, a cell line, or a zebrafish,
there's an upregulation of ERV RNA.
The truncating mutations work through a dominant negative mechanism and cause
sequestration of the ERV RNA in the cytoplasm away from the decay
machinery. And ERV RNA is necessary and sufficient for the
Z18-driven melanomagenesis.
You can see an earlier version of this manuscript in bioRxiv last year, and
hopefully the full one will be out soon.
Just a couple of discussion points.
As far as I'm aware, this is the second genetic cause of ERV elevation in cancer.
The first is loss of VHL in a beautiful paper by Zhang et al. earlier this year.
ERV RNA as a driver could explain the high expression in cancer
despite the known immunogenicity that is caused by ERVs.
And it's interesting that there may be this RNA
mechanism to work in concert with the DNA repression mechanisms to
control these dangerous messages.
So lastly, this is what I'm thinking about a lot, is how to
target these things. And so I hope I've convinced you that RNAs can be drivers
in cancer, and thus, because they can be drivers, they can be effective targets,
either through targeting the complexes directly or maybe through targeting the
RNAs. And this is ongoing work.
And I would love to thank the people who did the work.
Tanzina Tanu was the lead on this project, but it was really a collaborative effort
from my entire Nascent lab.
Our many collaborators, including Paul, thank you,
and funding sources. And with that, I'd be happy to take any questions.
Please remember to tell us who you are and where you're coming from.
Mustafa Alshani at St. Andrews in Scotland.
P53 is a transcription factor that is thought to
be controlling the transposable elements in their expression thereof and
repressing them. In melanoma setting, did you find that
P53 mutation is the initial
expression of these transposable elements, and then Z18 is the
failed gatekeeper, which then leads to viral mimicry?
What's the process of actually initiation of these
processes?
So I think we didn't specifically
look at plus or minus P53 in our systems to see how that is
regulated. I am sure that a ton of these different tumor
suppressors and oncogenes that we think about are going to regulate the dark
genome. We haven't looked at all. It's going to be there.
How functional it's going to be is going to be the key, I think.
So that's me opining.
Okay.
Hi, Kate Cecchelli from George Washington University.
This is really interesting work. Thank you for sharing.
I was curious about mechanism for the ERV1 RNAs.
Are they activating viral signaling, type I interferon signaling, so they're
binding to proteins in the cytoplasm?
In terms of their oncogenic effect, I was curious about that.
I am also very interested in that. I don't have answers yet because literally it
took my entire soul to get that amount of work done in the last year for the
reviews. But we are very interested in that. I have a bunch of experiments.
If you have ideas, I'd be happy to talk to you more.
Okay. I'll find you after.
Yeah. Thanks.
Hi, Kyle Tietz from University of Minnesota.
So you're seeing these accumulation of the ERV mRNAs.
So how are they driving oncogenesis?
Do you have a hypothesis on that?
I really don't know. I think
that there is going to be an RNA stress phenotype in
cancer. I think RNA's been harder to study.
A lot of the tools are only coming online now to make these...
Like with repeat elements, you need long-read sequencing really to figure out a lot
of this. So the tools are now available.
So now I think there is going to be a renaissance of effort in this area, and
then we can figure some of those things out.
Hi, I'm Jonathan Lichtman, Andal Institute. Again, very interesting work.
Kate, who just spoke before, has shown a decade ago that
upregulation of the ERVs has anti-proliferative effects.
So is there something about the genetic background of the melanoma that turns
off innate immunity or whatever is recognizing the endogenous
retrovirus and switches it from, in the case of DNA
demethylating agents, anti-proliferative to pro-proliferative?
Is there something special about this model or some subsets of cancer that allows
them to survive and thrive in the presence of these aberrant RNAs?
So I'm going to throw this forward to Omar because it really fits nicely with the
splicing factor field. It's been very difficult to make models.
It's been difficult to find the right context because oftentimes these are so
critical for cell fitness that if you just mutate them, the cells
slow down. But we're seeing that there's-They're selected
for in the cancers. That's the truth, right?
Like, and if we see them in the patients, there's got to be some advantage to the
cancer. So figuring that out, and I agree the tumor microenvironment is a
big... I'm suspicious it's going to play a role.
I don't have any data for that yet.
Okay. Well, we'll look forward to next year for more results.
So I have a question for you, Megan.
We've talked about this many times, but
maybe you could just tell us a little bit about what you're thinking.
What's the specificity factor?
Why is Z18 specifically
targeting these RNAs and not its other
normal substrates?
So I don't know, but I think it's, although I've had trouble getting it
funded through grants, everyone thinks that's a boring question, but I think it's
actually critical to understand some of these biochemical-- Like biochemically,
what is it recognizing? I suspect it may come
through some of the protein binding partners, and it may be that the ribonuclear
complex together offers some of the specificity.
Like some of it comes through those aromatic contacts that we
mapped, but some of it also may come through another binding partner.
I think also we have to keep RNA modifications on our radar
here because that, as we know in protein chemistry, that can dramatically
change specificity, and so I think that that's an important place to look, too.
Okay. If there are no more questions,
let's thank Megan.
And next up will be Omar.
All right. Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much to AACR for the opportunity to be here and participate in this
really nice event. I'm going to talk to you all today about some recent work we've
been doing trying to understand RNA regulation of anti-tumor immune
responses.
So these are some disclosures. So my lab is particularly interested in the
process of RNA splicing and its role in cancer.
And so for those of you not familiar, RNA splicing is one of several
nuclear steps that's really important in gene expression regulation
and
controlling the proteins expressed in cells.
I think most of us, when we learn about splicing, we learn that splicing is a key
mediator of protein diversity, and that's absolutely true.
But one of the things I'm going to highlight in the presentation today is that
splicing is also critical for regulating gene expression, and this happens
in part through, as Paul sort of hinted at, regulating where in the
transcript a stop codon is going to be located, but
also affecting the sequences of three prime and five prime untranslated
regions, which are really important in RNA localization, propensity for
translation, and stability of the
transcript. So as a hematologist, I became
interested in the topic of splicing right when I started my lab about 12 years ago,
when it was discovered that a high frequency of patients with certain blood
cancers have frequent mutations in RNA splicing factors, and these are
currently the most common mutations in patients with myelodysplastic
syndromes, present in up to 80% of those patients.
And I'm not going to talk about this topic much further in the presentation today,
but "Blood Cancer Discovery" was very kind to publish this In Focus article
coincident with the symposium today.
So if anyone wants to read about this topic, you can read this article there today
as well.
And so I became interested in this topic of how splicing might be important in
immune responses a few years ago. Last year, our group
identified that cancer cells with mutations in the splicing
machinery actually endogenously create mis-spliced transcripts,
which are a prominent source of neoepitopes on the tumor cell
surface that can be recognized by T cells specific
for those neoepitopes.
And this dovetailed with a number of additional stories identifying that splicing
alterations in cancer cells can be a very prominent source of shared
neoantigens through a variety of mechanisms.
And so as these papers were coming out, I became more and more interested in
thinking about could there be also a role in RNA
regulation in anti-tumor immune responses.
And so what I want to spend time today on is telling you all a new story related to
this topic specifically. So moving outside of the cancer cells
now to the immune cells that recognize them.
And we decided to focus specifically in a very specific context, which
is studying the process of T cell exhaustion.
Many of you are likely familiar with this, but it's very important in oncology and
also in infectious diseases, and it's the concept that with T cells, which begin as
naive T cells, begin to expose an antigen, either through a
virus or for cancer cells. They transition through persistent
antigen exposure through different cell states to form this terminally
differentiated cell state known as exhaustion.
And this is really important because these T cells are alive, they're present, but
they're not functioning properly to eliminate the antigen-expressing cell
or virus.
And this was really interesting because it's been previously really well defined
that each of these different transitional states from a naive to exhausted T
cells is characterized by very specific gene expression
programs, which are set up by specific transcription factors,
and there's specific chromatin states and DNA methylation states which are
unique to naive versus exhausted T cells.
And so many of you likely know this, but splicing largely happens
co-transcriptionally. So whenever there are situations where there's a unique
transcription factor state and chromatin state of a cell, there's often unique
RNA isoforms for that cell as well, and that's something that hadn't really
been well investigated, and certainly not in human cells.
So we had a very simple hypothesis to start with here, which is we hypothesized
that there would be alterations in splicing as key mediators of T cell
exhaustion in cancer.
To evaluate this, we started with patients with melanoma, where we sorted
out CD8 T cells from their tumors for patients with metastatic
melanoma, as well as their peripheral blood, and performed
single-cell long-read RNA seq of the CD8 T cells from these two different
compartments.And the goal here was just like conventional short-read
RNA-seq to capture the different T cell types based on their gene expression
characteristics, but hopefully now with the long-read to get closer to
full-length RNA isoforms unique to these different T cell states.
As it turns out, you can also use the long-read data to look at the clonality of
the T cells because you can capture their TCR alpha and beta chains.
And in really interesting data, which I won't get to talk about today, we can
now also start to resolve repetitive regions of the genome, which Megan alluded
to in her talk in melanoma cells earlier today.
So this is a UMAP of the four patients' blood and tumor T cells
from that prior slide, and they're colored based on their T cell state.
So the more purplish colors here are more exhausted T cell populations
and more green are memory-activated and cytotoxic T cells.
On the right here is a heat map of the marker genes used to define these different
T cell states, and this has been very well studied and published based on many
prior data sets of short-read RNA-seq data.
And if we look at the distribution within the blood or the tissues of where these
different T cells are located, we see that the purple
groups of the exhausted T cell populations are mostly enriched within the tumor,
whereas the non-exhausted T cells are mostly present in the blood.
And this is very well known because as T cells encounter
antigen within the tumor, they're more likely to be exhausted.
So there's an accumulation of exhausted T cells within the tumor tissue as
expected.
But what we wanted to really add now into this is, are there unique RNA
isoforms in the exhausted versus non-exhausted CD8 T
cells?
And so this is a volcano plot answering that question.
Every dot on this volcano plot is an RNA isoform, so it's
not a gene, but rather an isoform. And what we're looking at in purple
here is isoforms that are upregulated in the exhausted cells
versus those upregulated in non-exhausted CD8 T cell subsets.
And so there are a lot of interesting events here, many of which are previously
unannotated. They're not in reference databases for the
transcriptome and only resolve because of the long-read and the ability to look
at unique cell types, which are not really easily sequenced by bulk sequencing
efforts.
And you'll notice here that you'll see some gene names present on both sides of the
plot, and this represents genes that undergo an RNA isoform switching
event between exhausted and non-exhausted T cell state.
And so as we were looking at this data, we focused immediately on one gene in
particular because there's a very well role in T cell
exhaustion, and it's also a drug targeted melanoma, which is a
cell surface protein and immune checkpoint called LAG-3.
And you're seeing here two different isoforms of LAG-3, which are differentially
upregulated based on the state of the CD8 T cell.
So these are pseudo-bulk RNA sequencing coverage plots of
LAG-3 in the peripheral blood T cells, which are not
exhausted, versus the CD8 T cells in the tumor that are exhausted.
And what you're seeing here is there's a particular intron within LAG-3, which
actually has intron retention very prominently in non-exhausted
CD8 T cells, but in exhausted cells is very efficiently
removed. And if you look on the left here, this is the gene expression of the
parent gene in these different
tissue sites, and you see the upregulation of LAG-3 expression within the
tumor.
If we look at this in those more refined cell states from the single-cell data,
you see once again, as you go from memory activated in cytotoxic T cells to the
more exhausted cells, you see more and more efficient removal of this
intron.
And it turns out this intron is very important because it contains an in-frame
stop codon within it. And so the idea here is that this
retention of this intron would somehow influence expression of LAG-3,
either through triggering some form of mRNA decay or
truncated the transcript and protein early on.
And I should emphasize here, if you look again in reference databases, you will not
see a normal isoform that contains this interim retention.
It's something that is unannotated, but it does exist in normal cell states, in
particular, T cells.
Furthermore, for reasons I can't explain to you, even in our own
short-read deep RNA sequencing data, we don't see this differential
splicing event. It's really only been seen now through the use of long-read
sequencing.
And so again, for those of you not familiar with this, LAG-3 is an important cell
surface protein and an immune checkpoint, and it restrains T cell
receptor signaling, and it is the target of FDA-approved
antibodies targeting LAG-3 in combination with PD-1 for
patients with metastatic melanoma.
So it's an important role in T cell function and a drug target.
And it turns out you can induce this change in LAG-3 splicing in normal
T cells from normal donors. So if you take T cells from a normal donor and
acutely activate them versus chronically stimulate them,
chronic stimulation upregulates LAG-3 protein on the cell surface as well as
PD-1. And if you do the single-cell long-read in the
same CD8 T cells, you see very prominently again here the intron
retention event in the acute CD8 T cells, whereas the intron is
very efficiently removed again upon chronic stimulation of T cells.
And again, this correlates very beautifully with the level of LAG-3 mRNA
expression.
So the idea here is that there's an intron which is differentially excised based on
the state of the T cell. Exhausted T cells efficiently remove
this and give rise to the full-length protein coding form of LAG-3,
whereas acutely stimulated T cells actually have the intron retention event
normally under normal physiologic conditions.
And there's two possibilities here that are consequences of this.
The first is that this could trigger NMD, which as I'll show you, is actually
what's happening. But the other possibility before testing this formally is that
this could truncate the transcript and maybe even give rise to a truncated
LAG-3. The transmembrane domain is far more distal, so this would
still not be present on the cell surface.
So to try to evaluate this functionally, we created a minigene, so it's the entire
LAG-3 cDNA, but now contains this differential intron within
it.And so if you put an intronless LAG3 in cells, you see, of
course, only this short band here, which is the fully spliced form.
Wild type intron four, you have the spliced and unspliced.
And then as you create mutations within the intron, which force the intron
retention, now you have only this top band.
And in these same cells here, if you do a Western blot, you completely lose
LAG3 protein.
You can also see this by flow cytometry.
So we created a reporter now, which is again this LAG3 with the intron,
and then downstream is a GFP. And the idea here is that removal of this
intron would trigger LAG3 protein production as well as GFP,
but retention of this intron would block both proteins from being produced.
And so if you put these into cells, again, this will express LAG3 on the
cell surface as well as GFP. But as you force intron retention,
if you look down here, you completely lose surface LAG3 as well as
GFP production.
And so this was useful for us. We created a reporter from this and did CRISPR
screens to figure out regulators of LAG3 splicing, which I won't tell you
about further for now.
So what we've learned, as I've shown you so far, is that T cell exhaustion is
associated with a specific gene expression program.
It's very well studied previously.
But it's also associated with a specific RNA splicing
set of genes which are spliced characteristically in exhausted cells, one of
which is the splicing event in LAG3, which is important in T cell
function. We use this to create this reporter, and as we were doing
this work, we thought, instead of just using this splicing event to regulate
GFP, could we harness this splicing event to regulate gene expression
upon T cell exhaustion for some kind of therapeutic use?
And so the idea here was to use the splicing event in LAG3 to
differentially regulate some downstream gene of interest.
And so as we were thinking about this idea, several papers came out
describing that overexpression of a transcription factor called FOXO1
could mitigate T cell exhaustion in normal T cells and CAR T cells and
TCR T cells.
And so our thought was to try to use this splicing event now, just as LAG3 is
regulated in the cell upon exhaustion, use this to regulate a downstream
gene of interest.
And so this turns out to work very well.
So we have a mini gene now, which is just exon four to five of
LAG3, no other part of its coding sequence.
And then downstream is a P2A and the FOXO1 cDNA.
And we put these into T cells and look what happens to FOXO1 expression
upon acute versus chronic stimulation of the T cells.
As a positive control, we have constitutive overexpression of FOXO1, and a negative
control is a mini gene with no payload.
And so as you stimulate these T cells, you can do intracellular flow cytometry to
look at FOXO1 protein. In the acute setting,
FOXO1 is only upregulated in the positive control group, as
expected. But as T cells become chronically stimulated, now we
see the FOXO1 expression shifting to be upregulated
conditionally in the chronically stimulated T cells.
And it turns out that not only are we regulating FOXO1 expression, but
just as previously been published that FOXO1 mitigates exhaustion,
in the conditional LAG3 FOXO1 circuit, we
see downregulation of other immune checkpoints, LAG3, PD1,
TIM3, and the transcription factor Talks, and coordinate
upregulation of cytotoxic proteins like granzyme B and perforin.
So this splicing regulated payload of FOXO1 seems to be doing
something positive compared to just the constitutive overexpression.
So those are just in T cells that have not been engineered otherwise.
And I thought the best way to really to test this would be to put this into an
anti-tumor T cell, like a CAR or TCR T cell.
So I'll show you the last few experiments here where we did this.
So this is a T cell that has a TCR that recognizes a cancer testis
antigen, NY-ESO-1, commonly expressed in melanoma and
many other forms of cancer.
And then additionally, we've put in either FOXO1 as a positive control or
this splicing regulated form of FOXO1.
And we looked to see what happens to the tumor cells and T cells upon
repeated rechallenge of the T cells with tumor every 48
hours.
And so this is a graph now of the tumor growth over time in this
experiment, and the arrows here show the rechallenge happening every 48
hours.
In gray here is the tumor growth without T cells.
You can see the tumor cells grow unchecked as expected.
In blue are the TCR T cells against the tumor, which have an
anti-tumor activity as expected. And then the red is a positive control.
So FOXO1 overexpression promotes anti-tumor activity of the T cells
as previously been published. But you'll notice here in the yellow, this is the
splicing regulated FOXO1. As these T cells encounter repeated challenge,
now we see a separation of the curve, suggesting that there's some effect
now of temporally regulating this payload expression upon
tumor repeated challenge.
We've also done this in vivo, where we introduced the tumor cells in vivo and the T
cells, and once again, if you just focus on the yellow group here, the greatest
anti-tumor activity is in the splicing regulated FOXO1
expression.
And what I want to emphasize with this system is that we're not limited to
FOXO1. Anything you can clone into this vector can be temporally
regulated in this manner. And so just as one example, we
thought about other things that could be useful to regulate in this way, and one
idea is a cytokine, IL-12. This is a cytokine that's
well known to have anti-cancer properties, but if delivered
systemically, it also has great toxicity.
So there's been a great effort to try to develop local or temporal
delivery an expression of IL-12.
So the idea here is that this is now expressed downstream of the splicing
regulated switch to turn on and off IL-12 upon the state
of T cell stimulation. So the chronically stimulated cells
uniquely remove the intron to drive the IL-12
expression.And so just to show you that this is flow
cytometry now on the y-axis, looking at IL-12 in negative
control for splicing regulated IL-12.
So upon chronic T cell stimulation, IL-12 is now being
produced.
And it's well known that as IL-12 is produced, it also leads the T cells to
secrete interferon gamma. And so you can see here the interferon gamma production
very much mirrors that of IL-12. So this is a way to temporally
regulate a cytokine's expression upon chronic T cell
stimulation.
So to summarize, what I've presented to you all today is that it's very well
studied that T cell exhaustion is associated with a specific gene
expression program and epigenetic state.
But we've also now identified this is associated with a very unique RNA
isoform landscape of expression as well.
One of which splicing events are highlighted with this splicing event in LAG3,
which is previously undescribed and unannotated, but is very important in
regulating, physiologically, LAG3 transmembrane protein
expression in T cells. And so we identified that
acutely
activated T cells have this intron-retained form of LAG3, preventing the protein
from being expressed. But as T cells are chronically activated and
exhausted, this intron is efficiently removed,
providing LAG3 protein to be translated in those cells.
We then utilize this event now to temporarily regulate gene expression, just as
LAG3 itself is regulated in these cells, looking at therapeutic
payloads including FOXL1 and IL-12.
So I'll stop there. This work was led by a really talented postdoctoral fellow
at UCI in computational biology, Beatrice Zhang, in our group, and was
a collaboration with the other folks you see listed here, including really talented
surgeon scientists at MSK, Sharl Ailian, and T cell
biologists Chris Klebanoff and Santosh Verdanna.
So thanks so much for your attention and welcome any questions.
Hi, this is Yang from Thomas Jefferson University.
Great work. That's beautiful work.
My question is, do you know why the internal retention isoform
increase in the exhausted T cell?
Yes. So we've identified two RNA binding proteins, I didn't present this
in detail, that appear to regulate the splicing of that intron in
LAG3. At least one of them is upregulated itself
upon T cell exhaustion, so appears to be one of the gene expression
program of exhausted T cells. So basically, in short, we think that
there's an accessory splicing factor that's upregulated on the T cell state
that regulates that splicing event, is the general idea of what we think is
happening.
Mm-hmm. Okay. Thank you.
Sure.
Great talk.
Thank you.
Curious if you've looked at LAG3 in other T
cell types. So for example, Tregs also express
LAG3, SF4, all the other ones. But if
there's alternative splicing, potentially they could be targeted
separate, or just the CD8 exhausted T cells will be targeted, but not
Tregs.
Yeah. Evgeny, you might be one of my reviewers because we're asked that in review.
Working on that right now. So yeah, definitely.
CD4 T cells, NK cells, they all are thought to express
LAG3. Even some neuronal cells express LAG3 apparently.
So we're checking those now. Unfortunately, we're stuck doing single-cell
long-read RNA-seq, which is expensive and time-consuming, but we're working on that
now. I don't have an answer at the moment, but it's something we're evaluating.
We did look in normal donors, where I showed the data in CD8 T cells.
We also did CD4 T cells. But the LAG3 expression was so
low there, we didn't see very clear differential splicing the way we saw it in CD8
T cells. So that may end up being the answer, but we're looking now more
extensively in patient materials to answer exactly that question.
Okay. Thank you.
Sure.
Hi. I'm Michelle. I'm from UCL in London.
I was just wondering if
you have a feeling if the LAG3, that specific isoform
is allelic specific, because you have
long reads, so you can see if it's just knocked out in one or
both?
That's a really interesting question.
I had never thought about that until your question.
It'd be interesting to go back and look at that. But I have not thought about that.
And it's interesting because maybe there is something there
if it was allele specific that could point to the regulation a little bit more
finely than we've thought about currently. So thank you for asking that.
Thank you.
Yeah.
All right. I have a question for you, Omar.
Sure.
If nobody... Oh, go ahead.
Okay. Hi, Omar. John Lichtman Andel.
Could you comment in general about this-- It sounds like you've completely switched
to PacBio to do all this. Is it
no looking back? Should we not be doing even deep read, short read?
Should it only-- So tell me, because you didn't discover it even with pretty deep
reading with the
short read.
Yeah. That's a great question, John.
The unfortunate answer is there are benefits to both
short and long read RNA-seq. And if I had enough money, I would do both.
But unfortunately, it's obviously challenging to do both.
The pluses and minuses are you do discover a lot of
interesting new RNA isoforms, obviously with the long read RNA-seq as an example
here. But the depth of sequencing is also a limitation, and a lot
of the computational analyses is a limitation for interpreting and understanding
the long read RNA-seq. The other issue, which is practical, is still the
cost, I think, particularly of single cell long read is a challenge.
But yeah, there's pluses and minuses to doing both.
And certainly, there's quite a bit to discover, I think, from doing long read
RNA-seq compared to short read.
Thank you. And one other follow-up, the MBNL1, you did a CRISPR screen.
When you knocked that out, did this then stop the mis-splicing?
Yeah. So MBNL1 promotes removal of that intron to promote
LAG3 upregulation.
Okay.
Yeah, so.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
So I was going to ask,
I love this idea of taking artificial
introns, essentially, and using them to control gene
expression.
Are there other applications for this that you have in mind?
Yes. So we started this area, Paul, because actually in the context of
mutant splicing factors, we identified splicing events specific to the mutant
cells, and then we engineered what we call synthetic introns for the mutant cells.
So I took that idea and applied it here.
But I think any setting where there's differential splicing based on cell state,
one could engineer such a reporter, basically, for it.
So I think it's an exciting topic and application. Yeah. Thank you.
All right.
Okay, if there are no more questions, let's thank Omar again.
Thank you.
Okay. That concludes this session. Thank you all for coming.